I experienced screaming voices people
don't believe how insane
I am totally manic or totally depressed
and you know it wasn't him baddam we
knew I just wanted a car to hit me or
the truck or just something to take me
out because this time I wanted to really
work I really felt like I needed to in
my life I felt like I was this complete
failure
so I was in really bad bad shape and the
mental health system only made that
worse
it's a mythology to think that there's
no normal and then these diab mark the
average recovery rates in the Western
world with all our sophisticated
diagnosis and medications and highly
paid experts is about 1/3 the recovery
rate in the developing world is about
two-thirds where is somebody who's in
this delicate state you know their inner
process they sent to prison they're sent
to jail they're sent to a psychiatric
ward that are chemically incarcerated or
they're homeless in the United States
we've come to believe in the chemical
imbalance
Darry a mental disorder these medicines
are very very powerful in helping but
they can be very powerful and harming I
mean like the disclaimer on these pills
that's typically the first side effect
is suicidal thoughts and that's what the
doctor is giving you to feel better I
mean it's it's crazy do we live in a
psychotic Society we do and what is what
is meant by psychotic out of touch with
reality how mental illness is
constructed in different places in the
world is very very different only in the
Western world
have we developed this bizarre idea that
hearing voices and having strange ideas
has no meaning at all
my human rights work has taken me to
indigenous and tribal cultures around
the world often I met individuals who
would go into a trance-like state to
serve as a healer or visionary for their
community these are the people we call
shaman and I was surprised to learn that
many were identified in their youth by
having what we would call a psychotic
break hearing voices having visions
feeling terrified I was struck by how
differently these symptoms were looked
at in our culture we have lost touch in
our medical system from some of the
simple needs that people have for
connection the simple needs that people
have for community maybe it's not just a
broken brain maybe it's not just an
illness maybe this is not just something
to hide and be ashamed of maybe it's
something to explore and learn
[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sock young
very excited to be talking about
storytelling for social change
we have Phillip borders joining us on
the show hello yeah yeah yeah thank you
for coming on I pleasure I'm so excited
for yeah you've been doing such
important work around our world and I'm
so grateful that I stumbled upon it and
that now we're gonna be able to talk
about it at depth on the show for those
that don't know Phil's background he has
been documenting indigenous and tribal
cultures for over 25 years
striving to create an understanding of
the challenges they face his work is
exhibited in museums and galleries
worldwide in his award-winning books
which have been published in four
languages include Tibetan portrait
enduring spirit women empowered in Tibet
culture on the edge he has hosted
television documentaries on indigenous
cultures for discovery and National
Geographic channel's Phil also lectures
and teaches internationally his recent
project crazy wise which we just watched
the trailer of explores the relevance of
shamanic traditional practices and
beliefs to those of us living in the
modern world and you can find the links
in the bio below to Phil's website as
well as the crazy Weis film website and
the Facebook page for crazy wise film so
let's start things off with asking you
what are your thoughts on the direction
of our world who is everything you know
there's so much exciting new discoveries
there's so many young people that want
to get involved and change the direction
of some of the more negative things that
are happening and there's this which
surprised me this turned towards
individualism I would say turn to the
right we want to keep ours and and
protect ours driven I guess you know
really it's being driven by climate
change
Syria largely the disc the instability
there caused by the farmers not being
able to grow their crops in the
beginning that had some of the the
background of what caused all that
immigration to Europe and the
destabilization of that government now
the war same thing with a lot of the
people coming up from South America that
you know are so-called immigration
crisis so yeah there's this there's that
going on but yet there is this whole
mobilization of new thinking and it
where I've been in the last six years is
in the world of mental health and I
stumbled into a quite by accident came
out of my work Human Rights work in
indigenous and tribal cultures over a
25-year period and I began meeting these
healers and visionaries and learned how
they were identified so it brought me
and then I met a young kid in my
hometown of Seattle that he became the
main protagonists in our film crazy wise
and it brought me into the world of
mental health and how we're in crisis
right now I mean in the Western world
depression became the number one cause
of disability in 2017 and the World
Health Organization had predicted about
twenty years ago that by 2020 it would
be the number one cause well we reached
three years early suicide rates over a
15 year period were up 24 percent that's
huge
and and this is in the midst of us
trying to solve the problem
pharmaceutically biomedically and I
crazy bytes is not a anti Med film
because every mental health worker I've
talked to says they're glad they have
that in their toolbox but it's being
abused way overused it's looked at as a
lifetime solution it is not a lifetime
solution so yeah so I've been thrown
into that world and and and not only
seen the problem but seen this evolution
of what they call the recovery movement
people who have successfully navigated a
mental health crisis and proven you can
recover and they are forming a movement
they say this is what helped us this is
what didn't help us and that movement is
growing like mad now so there's a lot of
good and there's a lot of problems to
solve yeah
[Music]
there's something about the indigenous
wisdom that has been lost that in the
complexity of today's exponential
technology and geopolitical hodgepodge
of mayhem that's happening if we can
embed this ancestral wisdom into our
ethics and our philosophies and our
morals and our connection to nature we
can do that we can handle the future and
without that it's causing more
unnecessary suffering and I'm really
happy that you know that you're really
diving deep into this with mental health
I can't believe it's number one on
depression to some disabling people
right now worldwide and the over
prescription of pharmaceuticals that do
such complex things to our biology that
we can't actually fully simulate and
understand what's happening versus
practicing things like connection to
nature and deep connection to our own
essence and what our life purpose is and
these types of things about unity and
family and love yeah yeah yeah well it
became so it was impressed upon me
because I would go to do these zoo the
work I was doing I would go out for
about six weeks come back go out for
another two months come back back and
forth and I it's such a contrast going
into a tribal or an indigenous small
community than coming back here you know
first of all many of the places I go
they eat maybe three or four things when
their diet is amazing and not eat every
day and then come here and walk into a
Whole Foods grocery store and have just
you know that's all this choice and but
you know we've gained so much in the
direction we've taken that we've also
lost things and the thing I think we've
lost that I've noticed is connection
yeah yeah like you just said connection
to each other I mean they in these small
groups and this is the way our brain
evolved they have to be connected to
survive they don't have old-age homes
they have no institutions to that they
can farm out their old people to they've
got to take care of their old people
they have no daycare centers so the
women typically nurse each other's
babies yeah yet I've seen them past you
know one woman will pass her baby to
another woman's because she has to go
get the water in the well and then that
woman may have to go chase her goat so
she'll pass that baby to another woman
Wow
so they don't have these institutions
like daycare centres old-age homes
Medicare or Social Security yeah they've
got to provide that by forming deep
reciprocal connections to each other
yeah yeah so and then to themselves they
they have rituals traditions beliefs
that give them an outlet for their
creativity their self-expression where
they can express their emotions I mean
usually everybody in the group sings
yeah I'm embarrassed to say you know
we've got these professionals that are
so good at saying you say well I don't
want to but we can all sing we may all
dance and they sing and they're with
their bodies drumming a lot and so
yeah yeah yeah ready good things not bad
such a bonding thing scene yeah yeah
yeah no daycare no elderly care altruism
reciprocal altruism so evidently visible
and you know depth the thing is
connecting of course to nature and they
have to do that because they have to
draw all their own food so they have to
know all the flora and fauna and what is
poisonous what is not how it you know
and but on top of that they have this
metaphor of their being spirit energy
and everything being on mountains and
the rivers yes was so they're
spiritually connected on a deeper level
and you know the shamans I'll see
shape-shift into different animals and
take on that animal energy yes and so
they had this very tight connection that
I think we've lost partially lost or
vamping were a very individualistic
society I think especially America where
the cult of the individual you know
celebrity individual accomplishment you
know all these things are very strong
especially in our culture even compared
Asian cultures rates are more a little
more collective yeah
but in these cultures it's even it's
even more apparent how we are more
individually driven oh my gosh so much
gets stuff right there so so let's start
with how you mentioned there is this
deep dry for altruism there's this deep
dry for rituals for singing for even you
know passing the babies during for
breastfeeding when you want us to go do
an activity that the you have to know
the flora and fauna that are local to
your area rather than all the corporate
logos that are trying to self deal
themselves into your life there's the
spirit energy and everything that that's
so beautiful when you can do things like
really get behind the essence of another
bring that creatures experience into
your own state of awareness and that way
you can then gain a greater sense of
empathy and get yourself out of your own
body and connect with all that is that
these things help us get gained a true
insight into the reality and when we're
so deep into individualist culture we
lose sight of our interconnectedness and
that you were you said this and I just
want to say it may even be that so many
of the indigenous cultures are saying
that our disconnection from nature our
disconnection from source from spirit is
the exact reason why we have so many of
the malevolent says that errors the
issues that exist in our civilization
yeah so if we can mmm if we can
basically pull these two worlds of the
craziness of building the artificial
general intelligence is with the
indigenous wisdoms if we can kind of
bring these two worlds together
yeah we can build where we want to go
better yeah yeah Phil it's so important
for us to understand who you were as a
kid at growing up you're born here in
Oakland yeah Bay Area yeah and you're
born in 42 right yes 76 now yeah years
old and so born in 42 that's still in
the middle of the second world war and
there I mean what's going on in the
world at that time and who are you
growing up how do you get interested in
writing and in film and art photography
how fantastic he looks great
that's a long story
I was born here in Oakland the important
parts I think in my life that happened I
had an older sister 13 years older and I
had a younger sister a year and a half
younger my dad dies when I'm seven and
that's a major event in my life I the
teacher I don't remember this but my mom
told me that the teacher said I just
stared out the window for that entire
year it left a deep mark on me there's
the reason why he what was the reason
why but he died of lung cancer is a
heavy smoker
he died of 43 smoking three packs a day
43 he was so young yeah yeah yeah
so then we moved to San Lorenzo which is
part of these Bay and I it was kind of a
lower middle-class family mixed
neighborhood which was nice but we were
as kids kind of like hoods but not bad
hoods and I got involved in I was an
entrepreneur so I got involved in
firecrackers which were illegal and a
kid across the street told me how I
could get him I could go down to
Chinatown and Oakland and there was one
grocery store you could go in the back
room and give them the money and tell
them what you wanted and then go out on
the street and stand at a certain corner
and the card come by and throw that so
anyway I ended up with this firecracker
business in San Lorenzo when I was about
10 11 12 and it got me several
infractions with the police yeah
and my mother worked all day so you know
I would just pray that the police had
begun by the time she got home and I'd
buried the firecrackers in the backyard
but anyway I got enough in trouble over
that that she sent me to a ranch that my
older sister had married into in Utah
whoa and so all of a sudden I went from
this kind of tract development you know
as kids getting in trouble all the time
to this ranch that was in this beautiful
valley it was a little community much
like the communities I visit mm-hmm you
know all Mormons so one one religion one
belief they helped each other build
their barns we helped each other haul
each other's hay cut each other's hay
bale it do all the things through the
farm we didn't go to the grocery store
yeah grew our we raised all our own food
made our own soap I mean it was like and
I just blossomed in that it it literally
kept me from going down the wrong path
and the other thing that changed for me
is my mom moved from San Lorenzo to
orinda which is an upper-middle-class
and I went from not really doing
anything in school to these kids being
around these kids that were great
students and had I didn't even speak
very good English and almost I'm
throwing in there and that took me a
while to catch up you know as a freshman
in high school
so that was a big change in my life and
I don't know how much detail you want me
to go and keep going the story's great
please so anyway I finally started doing
well in school mainly one teacher turned
me around one guy stopped me in the hall
because he knew I wasn't doing homework
at home because I do it right before
class five minutes whip out my algebra
and he said if you came up to me in the
hall once and he just stopped me and he
said Phil you know most of these kids
are at home doing an hour and a half of
homework I see you whip out yourself
you're getting a see but that's amazing
you can do that five minutes I'm gonna
see if he said if you applied yourself
yeah it might really surprise you and
then he just walked on and it just I was
just sat there sort of stunned
so I started performing for this guy
nice and got an A in the class and then
I mean I started off with D's and F's
and by the time I got out of high school
I was getting pretty much A's and B's
how long do you spend in Utah before you
came back I would spend the whole summer
there and I did that right through high
school okay that's right last year as a
senior because I was saving up to go to
college okay and then and by the way my
family is Mormon and and while I'm in
high school
I'm going to church like nine times a
day a week nine teams a week yeah three
times on Sunday I'm five times before
school for seminary and one Tuesday
night called mutual so I was totally
immersed in Mormonism yeah and and my
first year to go to college I decided to
go to Brigham Young University and Utah
and I really got disillusioned with the
church at that point slightly the
this is in the 60s by the way 1960 civil
rights movements just started to take
off in the Mormon Church any person of
color especially an african-american
could not hold the priesthood and every
male gets to hold the priesthood that's
the power in the Mormon Church and
they've changed that since then the
Mormons tend to try to keep up with the
evolution of our of our culture
and anyway so I was becoming
disillusioned and I was running out of
money living away from home I came back
the next year and transferred to
Berkeley mhmmm so Brigham Young to
Berkeley
another big kind of it was like San
Lorenzo to orinda you know and and I
became an atheist basically whoa you
know I just thought religion you know
this is just everybody's fear of death
it's a nice fairy tale to use everybody
about that and I stayed that way until
then I graduate from Berkeley and I go
to UC Med Center here in the city living
on Parnassus in the Haight Ashbury
district from 65 to 69 right during the
summer of love and all the hippie stuff
going on and playing around a little bit
with drugs you know marijuana a little
bit a little bit of psilocybin but not
much mainly going to school and a couple
of things happen
one I went just as a joke to a psychic
that was out on the avenues Madame Russo
was her name and she was kind of this
heavyset woman set in this
living room folding chairs where people
could come in and you would write your
questions on a piece of paper put them
in an envelope in a basket and then she
would take that basket
during hers she had the big picture of
Jesus behind her and in that basket she
would hold these envelopes one at a time
like Johnny Carson did if you remember
Johnny Carson the great Christian told
them you know and but she had hold him
in her hands and she would answer the
questions so I wrote down how old am i
where was I born
I forget all the question mundane
totally mundane question so she's
answering all these questions for these
people these people are totally into it
they're good yes you're right on oh my
god oh she comes to mind and she just
sat there for a minute she went
you know this person's testing me I wish
you wouldn't do it there's a lot of
people here that really have legitimate
concerns and it's really wasting their
time and then she just put it aside went
on the next person so that kind of
caught my attention you know how did she
do that
yeah and so I came again and watched the
basket to make sure no one was slipping
her answers behind this but she could do
that and I began asking there legit of
my questions and she was pretty right on
and I and that was happening and my mind
was opening a little bit with the
marijuana and the seller side band and
so I started opening again to this close
you know thought about what reality is I
guess and this is at the time of the big
counterculture yeah right but I had a
job
work-study job to stay in school while I
was in dental school interviewing the
hippies on the street why were they
using the drugs with needles and if we
gave them free needles would they use
those needles so I was doing this for a
psychologist so I would sit on the
street pick out one of the freakiest
people coming down the street to
interview to make my day interesting and
ask him which drugs are you using which
drugs are you shooting if you had free
needles would you use them and I started
taking photographs of them so I took out
a little student loan got a Minolta SRT
101 and started photographing them along
with my interviews that's kind of what
I'm doing now
so that's where my photography kind of
really started during dental school
mm-hmm
and even yeah
and you keep doing that while you did
this
18-year career as a dentist - no you did
- I wrote it aside because I built my
practice in and I got into that and and
then when my son was born I took out my
old Minolta loaded with black-and-white
film filmed his birth and then I didn't
have any place to develop the film so I
went to this Community College I was
living up in Sonoma in the wine country
and I took the film to a one-hour lab
they couldn't do it so I went over to
Napa Community College and they had this
darkroom they said if you I asked about
if I could use it and they said yeah but
you got to take a class here so I
thought okay I'll take a class and I got
this instructor that was totally in fact
I just saw him before I came down here
from I live in Seattle Ron Zack was his
name is his name and he was so
inspirational I got totally turned on to
photography fell in love with it head
over heels even more than when I was in
dental school and decided I am going to
go into this I'm gonna leave my practice
and go into this so over the next year
and a half I kept taking his classes and
at the same time I brought in somebody
to replace me and my practice and then I
moved to Seattle and declared myself a
photographer and and of course my son
was just a baby at that time so I had
the responsibility of and my wife didn't
work at the time a wife in a child and
so it was real scary make that
transition and and I started doing
commercial work it took me three years
to get my first job Wow
you know it was a hard to break into it
then I started becoming successful as a
commercial
photographer and then I decided you know
I got this one job where they had me
illustrating romance novel covers and I
did about 30-40 of those and as I was
doing those I just said to myself is
this what I quit Orthodontics for
although as loving photography and just
about that time I met a woman who had an
organization in Seattle advocating for
Tibetan rights what was going on in
Tibet this is the early 90s now and just
a light bulb went off in my mind I'm
going to Tibet and I'm in a document
what's going on and rather than the
commercial yeah I took I was paying
$1,000 a year to put my photos in a a
book that went to all the art directors
that's how you made it in commercial
photography I stopped putting my
thousand dollars a year into that and I
put it into some trips to Tibet whoa and
that changed everything because I didn't
have a business plan it wasn't like I
did it to make money I just wanted to do
it and long story short my first book
came out of those images people started
buying my images and galleries pretty
soon I had galleries all over the
country selling my work then I then I
didn't have to do commercial work
anymore
and so I've been doing these you know
anything like the social or
environmental issue that turns me on I
put my camera to that and started
telling stories and I would do it mainly
with portraits mm-hmm because I love
that process of making a good portrait
of somebody what I consider you know
tortured anyway you capture their spirit
at an exact moment in time in their
candid yeah look of just being there and
somewhat being a little vulnerable or
just young and so I would put those
individual portraits together in an
exhibit and it would tell the story that
I wanted to tell Lincoln Tibet yeah how
is I started with the refugees including
the Dalai Lama
living in Dharamsala India then I went
into Tibet and documented the people
there and just kind of put that together
in a book in this story so that's what
I've been doing pretty much for the 25
years and during that time meeting by
chance first with the Dalai Lama's
Oracle the nature Oracle and then other
healers in these communities visionaries
people we call shaman yeah and they go
by different names in their communities
and learning how they were selected and
it was fascinating to me to hear that
they were selected mainly by having an
intense crisis in their life often it
was sometimes a physical crisis where
they almost died from a high fever or
something but most often it was a
psychological a mental emotional crisis
where they were seeing visions or
hearing voices they were very frightened
and usually an elder would take him
aside and tell them that you've got a
special sensitivity yeah it's difficult
but
you can learn to manage it yeah and once
you do it's going to be very useful to
the community that's abuse oh it was
such a contrast to what I later learned
and I did that for 25 years interviewing
people like this and then I meet a kid
in Seattle that had a psychotic break
when he was 20 it's a very typical age
for that was told he had a chemical
imbalance of his brain and that it can
be rebalanced with these pharmaceuticals
but you cannot be cured so you're gonna
probably have to be on these for the
rest of your life so you missus cannot
be cured there's so many unlimited
possibilities for what could potentially
help cure yeah right but we I don't
think any was anybody's doing that
maliciously they just didn't know they
didn't know we don't know we're afraid
of non-ordinary states of consciousness
basically yeah and they're frightening
to a family because when you go into
some of these and I've interviewed many
people that have gone into these states
now and so I can say that what I've
learned is that when you go into one of
these states you do have somewhat of a
personality change I mean you look at em
world very differently yeah and and the
thing that's fascinating to me now is
part of that looking at it differently
you feel more a part of everything your
ego boundaries dissolved to a certain
extent
and you so you have the sense of oneness
and bliss in the beginning many times
but then a concern to terror and fear
over for several reasons one the fear
coming from the people around you your
family your lover mmm your boss that
knew you one way and you're trying to
explain this thing that's happening to
you yeah and there's really no good
language to explain it and so they get
scared and the other thing about being
and he's becoming a crazy person we need
to go and lock him up our we need to go
and throw pharmaceuticals in them in the
brain yeah no no no just some point the
gifts of these experiences to be able to
share them with the right sometimes
family may not be the right people to
share it with right so and then we need
to be ready to find and sometimes it
takes a little bit of time to find the
right community the right friends the
right people to share these experiences
with and then get this that validation
that this is something that people
experience these non-ordinary states of
consciousness yeah these ones that can
give us so much more insight into the
nature of reality yeah yeah yeah usually
there are very they're very bright
individuals that this happens to usually
they're very creative they look they
think outside of the box so and right
now the tragedy is most of them are
ending up in jail or on the streets
homeless
or heavily some people call it
chemically incarcerated so yeah it's
really kind of a tragedy what's going on
but it's also getting better so that's
the good news because a lot of these
people that have had these experiences
are speaking up now you know so
stigmatized they usually didn't speak up
yeah it was like being gay back in the
nineteen sixty and so they're starting
to come out and speak up and say yeah
this happened to me and when I go around
showing crazy wise and I've shown it
yeah all over Europe and here in the
United States there's people that stand
up in the audience and come out for the
first time that happens quite a bit so
wow it's just you know that's what it's
going to take it's just more people
saying yeah this is this is a human
natural human experience and it's
actually a potential growth process if
supported and contextualize properly yes
and the way we're contextualizing it now
as a broken brain many times with the
words there's really no cure and you can
function you may not be able to do it
everything you had your heart set on and
your goals but you will be able to
function in our society more or less and
you tell a young kid that that's like
putting a hex on them especially if
you're in a white coat in a person of
authority like a doctor
and it it's just a negative placebo
effect and the placebo effect is very
strong yes
versus you can do this yeah are you
first find your purpose and you can find
meaning and do that every day and fall
in love with who you are and what you
care about and find good friend Amelie
and community around you then that's the
positive effect that we can have yeah
yeah yeah
yeah and but yeah that's what the
messaging crazy bytes is you know you
need that support you need the community
you need those relationships you need to
be given space to have this come out and
what's many times it could be driven by
past traumas there's a lot of different
scenarios why somebody would slip into
these none
I call them extraordinary states and
yeah just a different way of supporting
and in looking at them
the shaman you know they have the
advantage they have first of all it's
not pathologized yes
secondly they get a mentor it's usually
an older shaman so going through it yeah
they know that so-called healing they
know what it is the sensitivity yeah
yeah and third they have a community
that honors them and respects them and
gives them purpose and said yeah you're
valuable to us it's it's like the you
know boys go on from whizzed oh is when
we had them on a show they're building a
community right now I they have about a
half a million people in this community
where they can get the mentors connected
with other people that have experienced
similar things as as you may have when
you may have had a difficult experience
that when you learn their wisdom
it's called wisdom wisdom WISD oh it's
an online community five hundred
thousand people are in this community
now and less and so yeah yeah you can
get connected with people that have had
these similar difficulties and then you
can start talking to them about in
getting that mentorship about the
sensitivity that you now have so I'm
gonna have to yeah my web will get yeah
we'll get these things connected we'll
get you in so we're still yeah we'll get
you guys connected with what's going
yeah
then they're moving fast when were they
created it's really Israeli company we
created a couple years I know a couple
years ago okay great yeah yeah they're
moving fast and and so these are these
are some of the examples of like okay
can you imagine if the society is
pathologizing these sensitivities it's
inevitable we're gonna have a unneeded
suffering but when you're saying okay
this person had some sort of a difficult
experience
now let's pair it we you can get through
this is parrot with a mentor a community
people that can help get through that
experience now you've trained your
sensitivity to that experience you can
help others you can achieve your
creative endeavoring in the world at a
it's just like this is I love it I love
how all these pieces connect yeah yeah
plus the person that's helping that
helps them yeah the person that becomes
the peer that's helping the person's
going through it that they're called
wounded healers that's basically what a
shaman is that wounded healer yeah
I love that I've heard that like that
the wounded healer
I wonder yet because it probably makes
the healer better that they have went
through a difficult experience before
and that they're able to relate to that
it's like when you say that you know if
you have previously started a business
or if you've previously done art or
you've previously done science
experiments you're a better scientist or
business person or an artist yeah
because you've done it previously if
you've done these challenging things
you've gone through them before okay I
mean there's still so much to talk about
what the books that you've made I mean
all of the photos that you've taken are
just they're gorgeous captures and it's
so great that people found out about it
and then helped fund the artwork to be
shown these porters to be shown in
galleries and museums places that more
people can then go and gain an
understanding of these indigenous
cultures so they not only gain that
understanding but it also helps fund
your next steps your continued accept
that's the way to move art in the world
is to have it be identified as something
that can help awaken and get into the
right places for people to go and visit
those places and then also to fund those
artists continued pursuits but yeah
um okay let's the so crazy wise was
actually kick-started by over 700 people
mm-hmm which is very cool as well you
did your homework yeah which is so cool
yeah that was yeah I mean I did I didn't
even know that audience really I mean
people that would be interested in this
subject because I had never even delved
into it before it wasn't something I did
and yeah to get all that support from so
I knew there were a lot of people
wanting that message out there and and
so we're slowly growing this thing and
and and I I really for me it's my
spiritual journey yeah you know I mean I
you know this whole sense of feeling of
oneness to me when I use the word
spiritual I'm using it as something that
connects us to the whole yes you know
something that brings us back to that
realization that were part of the whole
right yeah and so to find out that so
many of these people that went to Adam
in our film set it right off the bat in
our first interview so when I started
this film I was just doing a film on
mindfulness and so I was working with
the producer who was just sending me
people the interview that were
meditators and she sent me Adam and
Adams story that he was told this you
know biomedical reason for his is
craziness he said you know when it first
happened
it was very fun and exciting it was like
my ego shattered he said it was the
first time I've felt at one in the
universe where I was hit and it was me
and then I kept going and then I went
way too far and then it got scary so
I've heard stories like this over and
over again that was the first time I'd
ever heard it but you know did this
first interview with Adam and so that
whole that whole experience now I've
learned now I mean kind of into the
neuroscience but yeah interviewing
people that are really doing there's a
whole Renaissance in psychedelic
research yes going on right now
and and it's so important for it to be
decentralized and open source and done
for the right ethical reasons moral
reasons and not to fall under the same
forces that are greed or corruption yeah
well and also you know what happened
when I was in my 20s with Timothy Leary
and the whole you know set and setting
first set is so important you've got to
have an intention what do you want to
have come out of this experience right
yeah and then setting is good to have a
guide that's been through it yes and
that can help you as things get
frightening yeah because typically it
involves an ego dissolution yeah
we don't want to die the shaman calls
their initiation the little death the
little death yeah and we don't want to
die you know we you know you build up
your you know I feel Borgess I'm this
well-known photographer I don't I don't
want all that to go away well but these
little deaths can be so valuable because
then they make it so that we don't get
so attached yeah yeah yeah and and I
just want to quickly see before you
continue on the story
you gave this really profound couple
steps that people go through which is
now becoming more and more common in in
the mainstream we're slowly removing the
taboo around talking about mental health
and how things like when we dissolve our
ego and we get to these unbounded states
of feeling infinite a hole with
everything then sometimes it can feel
like that that mind expect all expansion
itself is like oh my gosh that was crazy
that was so far now you there's almost
like a Oh God there has to be community
present there so you have to have this
like powerful intent and then a powerful
community this guide these types of
things that can help ground again and
say that are you okay like that was good
in you're okay like we can help um with
the vibration you've got to integrate it
yeah yeah and that is a step by step
process and when Adam said I went too
far
he went further than he was able to
integrate it into this reality
and and it's like like I said earlier
before we started taping I'm learning to
set my boundaries you know I'm kind of a
guy that caves in sometimes when I
shouldn't gave in to others suggestions
and just to keep the peace and keep
everybody happy and at the same time I'm
trying to dissolve those boundaries and
so it's it's it's an interesting process
but I'm putting the idea so since the
film I've started thing called crazy
wise conversations and I'm doing much
like what you're doing interviewing
people loved it and people that have had
these experiences and and talking about
people to people about what it what it's
like to go too far and how do they
ground themselves again what techniques
do they use to reground yeah and I'm I'm
pretty sure that that's what the shaman
learns in their initiation takes usually
takes a year or two is yeah how do you
keep your foot in both worlds
yeah the world of dropping that's great
your sense of ego your sense of self and
then coming back and using that
knowledge and space you were in to
contribute to the world yeah and be able
to do that and you've got to have an ego
to work in this world so wow it is a
it's it's quite a balancing act and I've
got one woman I started interviewing who
was diagnosed bipolar and she is she
loves going into that space slightly
that manic part she calls a hypomanic
because her creativity shoots up yeah
yeah yeah she she's a writer in the
world
just flow yeah but when she's not in
that space
she's very tense and and constrained but
yeah she can't stop it from going too
far and yeah this is a long discussion
and I'm talking a lot but it's so good i
shorten it going too far you know we
look at the world through models through
mental models yes that are constructed
in a part of our brain that they're
starting to talk about now it's called
the default mode Network and these
mental models are just what we've
learned growing up about reality and so
we don't have to you know we're just
bombarded with all the sensory data
visual auditory proprioception taste all
that and
and now about computing and social and
Internet yeah yeah and so we have to
make mental shortcuts to deal with all
this and we do and so if you look at a
tree it's just a tree you can just put
it in a category tree you don't have to
go up and talk to you what it smells not
like you know feels and we do that with
everything and so we're absolutely like
the icons it's a building icon it's a
car icon it's a human icon yeah yeah
instead of the nuanced when you get
closer to it you smell it touch it taste
it look at it in its eyes the very soul
yeah yeah yeah
and because it would just be
overwhelming to be constantly do we guys
so this default mode Network they call
it the Ghoulies neuroscientists call it
the grand conductor because it kind of
helps us build those models yep and so
there's a positive aspect to it but
there's also a negative aspect to it
because if you've built so many models
and you become
so rigid and you're thinking and you're
really not seeing things as they really
are you're seeing it through these
models if that makes sense yeah and
especially if those models are negative
mm-hmm if those models of especially of
your own self how you consider yourself
and because also that narrative self
that we create is a mental model and if
it's really stuck in a negative place
you get your depression your PTSD your
OCD obsessive-compulsive disorder eating
disorders all those type of disorders
are too because of too rigid of a system
it's like what Laura says when I'm in
that space I can't write and words don't
flow I can't make my jewelry I can't I
don't get those inspirations that I used
to get yeah but she says when I get into
that space of hypomania and that all my
words are flowing and everything those
mental models are starting to dissolve
the default mode Network is starting to
shut down
but then if it shuts down too much it's
like I get to a space and this is in her
words it's on our website where I have
to find something that everybody knows
is real like the Sun rises the Sun sets
yeah because I'm not sure of anything
else hmm
I mean so it can get to where it's
terrifying and a lot of people end up
you know with all the symptoms of a
psychosis that we associate with having
to be shut down yes so
it's it's really interesting in terms of
this spiritual you know breaking down
the models the model of the ego and all
that
anyway it's fascinating stuff and
there's all these guys working on it now
yeah with fMRI imaging to see how the
brain changes and how this network this
default mode Network shuts down and
somebody not in a psychosis because
they've never been able to test that but
how it shuts down with somebody on heavy
dose of LSD or heavy dose of psilocybin
or a monk that's been meditating for a
long time yeah their default mode
network is shut way down yeah and so and
I'm sure it it would be the same with
somebody that's had a near-death
experience or a hardest that's totally
lost in their work where their sense of
self goes away in their doubt just right
in the moment deep flow yeah yep extreme
sports or something like that these
things are so deeply interconnected so
deeply interconnected all these fields
the flow the flow deep flow States the
meditation States the psychedelics that
the this grand conductor of the default
mode Network creating such a rigid safe
way to to conserve energy by just saying
tree icon instead of going deeper into
the tree and smelling touching looking
at the ecosystems within the tree that
are there there's so much there and then
also just the importance of having one
foot in this yes
physical world where I'm in this body
but at the same time having one foot out
of this physical world when I'm where
I'm in this body and being connected to
all that is this unbounded wholeness of
everything from a moment-to-moment basis
and being in that style of life where
you can be in both and do it in a way
that is mentally healthy can be
transformative for you achieving your
maximum destiny in the world being great
with your family in your community and
just having a healthy functioning
civilization and I mean these things are
so damn interconnected yeah yeah are you
able to do it I'm starting to get better
and better at it and trying to do it as
healthy as healthfully as I can so how
do you go better doing it hello
and one of the I think one of the most
simple ways for everyone and we've
talked about this on the show is that
the the fact that there is something
that there is life that we are all alive
versus they're not being this
opportunity to be alive that first and
foremost needs to be what we are
extremely grateful for on a
moment-to-moment basis the fact that we
are alive
yeah and that we all come from something
yeah okay then it's that this these
these breaths of air keep me alive and
that I'm deeply interconnected the
breaths of air that I take and so are
you and we all have to do that but then
we also have to drink this water so then
we all do the same thing with the water
every time we take a drink we remember
that and then all of a sudden the
interconnectedness is with you all the
time it's with you every breath it's
with you every drink of water every bite
bite of food every time you look at
someone in the eyes you see them as a
divine being
everything changes your whole life
changes and that's something to share to
other people it's not a rigid thing that
you push on to people it's something you
say see how this feels for you
II cracked practice it at your own
expression mmm be your own artist with
it hmm I like that and you do that and
you've been doing it for a while for
just a little bit especially through the
help of indigenous leaders have been
helping me know really the Kogi tribe
has been mom and luige Alana has been a
big one that has helped me tremendously
with this and we were fortunate enough
to interview mom and it was a really
really good one I saw on our channel
it's a really good one and then we we
also interviewed the the seal Foundation
which made the 12th film and then they
went and did 12 12 of these indigenous
leaders gathered in um at the United
Nations headquarters to move the
trajectory of the planet
more beneficial direction and that's how
I discovered crazy Weis film through our
friend Nashawn who then said check who
aren't Brenda Shawn who's gonna be
speaking at our at our upcoming event
next week told me about crazy Weis film
and because I sent him our interview
with with mom in New Age Wan and he and
he said that these things have been
coming from all different angles he said
vision it's wisdoms and he said crazy
wise came into my life here let me pass
into your life and I got crazy wise and
I was like oh my gosh is this so cool
that this is happening now we have to I
have to email the team and see if
anyone's coming through the area so we
can interview them and you're like hey
I'll be there in a week or two let's
yeah let's make it happen yeah that's
how all these things come together and
it's just it's just one of those really
simple practices that you that the air
the water the food is very simple things
just being alive yeah but do it in your
own way do it in your own artistic
expression it's not a top-down force it
it's more like yeah try it out see how
it feels great what it does yeah I like
it yeah I like it a lot I'm so happy to
hear that yeah oh this has been such a
such a good conversation around did we
move did we throw any of the videos
throughout did we get any of those in
there no no
well let's throw let's throw in at least
um one of the Siberia mo
it has the yeah let's do this on footage
here so this is in Siberia so teach us
about this this is in Bulava Siberia the
eastern part of this of Siberia out of
ha bras and I'm just I went there to
meet about three or four shaman and they
were all older women and this is Emma
mama Emma as they called it and I'm just
here explaining I guess the audience has
audio on this oh you want to hear the
yarn
okay but three knocking over myself
way to go that anyway yeah she's well
Emma was the first woman
and she's also one of the strong
showings in this town in the lava so
she's definitely got a lot of respect in
this community in the og community and
she had these glasses that were kind of
asking some lay mind deciding how to
cross and make this image but she would
look at in on the ride through those
thick lenses and listening around the
problem of her collapses and the black
accessorized range look sighted at you
faced her off so I decided to face her
off camera and shooting a diptych mm-hmm
so that was just about kind of how I go
about making an image this is this young
girl here has all the symptoms of being
a shaman this whoa yeah Sasha and so I
wanted to do an image of her in the
armor River where she lives and so this
is just showing me how i watching images
and yeah she wore her signs you have for
a shaman well she was having visions and
hearing voices and but Linda the older
woman that I don't think we've shown yet
that I interviewed over there there
who's Lindsay 89 years old she dies
three weeks after I entered
so that would have been Sasha's mentor
okay
so I don't know what happened to Sasha
she ever got training I lost touch with
with them so I hope she did but yeah you
know there were only a few all these
women had to go underground during the
Soviet Union because there was no
religion allowed this is in Mongolia
this is with the SOT and people the
reindeer herders they live in teepees
much like the Native Americans and this
is a shaman going into trance to help a
young boy that some I think he had a
very high fever and and you can see that
it's a pretty wild thing to look at as
they do their you know getting
themselves in that state and while he's
doing it you know outside life is just
going on
and
you'll see that he comes out of it kind
of
he's been somewhere else it's obvious
when he comes out
and then he usually gives instructions
to the family what they need to do and
you know many times it's you see he's
he's coming back there
many times it's like you know I saw one
shaman woman nammed give this lady
having trouble with their pregnancy had
her make this kind of thing out of cloth
and then said bring this to the mountain
spirits so it was like they do things
like that reconnect with nature some way
much like you're saying you know
remember have gratitude remember that
you're part of everything that you're
taking in and giving out all the time
and so it's out there healings seem very
metaphorical the ones I've seen and yeah
yeah and so the the series of you going
on-site to different indigenous cultures
is you both capture individual portraits
and you capture of the film these these
non-ordinary states of consciousness
through shamans yeah a few I haven't
done that many okay you know I I stayed
away from that so when I'm doing this
interviewing of shamans over that
25-year period I have no idea I'm going
to be making the film on mental health
or delving into consciousness or any of
this stuff so I look back and say oh
yeah I could have done a much better job
I would have really delved more into the
initiation process how do you teach
somebody to ground when they're going
out too far and getting frightened you
know dropping their metal not other
however we want to contextualize it
losing there you go how do you teach
somebody to be able to go back and forth
like that yeah and I if I had to do it
all over again I would be definitely
drilling down on that number
I didn't there's more room to go and do
it yeah yeah we need it we need it now
more than ever we need film photography
art or around spirituality and we need
science to work with spirituality yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's kind of coming I
mean your interview here is kind of
getting me in that direction again
and I've been invited to Stockholm and a
couple of months to where there's going
to be a gathering of indigenous elders
so I may take another round at this
we'll see yeah yes
yeah and it's but yeah I'm just taking
one step at a time I'm just kind of
letting it unfold I'm not trying to get
uptight about planning what I need to do
next and hopefully yeah let it flow more
you know yeah then I have done things in
the past sometimes yeah yeah yeah that's
a good to be a cool congregation of
indigenous elders in Sweden yeah I think
so but no I thought this is kind of a
loose group organizing here and but yeah
yeah I think it could be something good
and also to get children around the
world interested in doing what we just
mentioned with spirituality I think is
so so critical to yeah that future
harmony that we need Phil I'm curious do
you where do you think do we do we come
from somewhere into these physical
bodies on earth and then do we go back
afterward what do you think about about
that well you know I think about it but
I have no idea I mean I I have an idea
but I wouldn't say I know anything what
is your idea about it well I think that
that could make some sense
the Tibetans sure believe it you know
reincarnation there and I honored the
Tibetan culture as an advanced culture I
honor the Dalai Lama as a very evolved
human being I've spent enough time
around him watching him and I'm usually
suspicious of leaders and authority
figures but I watched you know him be
with people that have just come out of
Tibet because a lot of people xscape
from Tibet
and go in to Dharamsala and they're the
new arrivals and he meets each one of
them and you know and these people think
he's a god I mean they look at him as
and sometimes they faint right in front
of and he'll be with them and you know
make sure they're okay make sure they
have a room and you know and the
handlers want to keep moving him on
because he has all these appointments so
he's you know and I've seen him
interviewed on TV with I think it was
Larry King or somebody at the time and
asking him what he thought about the
Chinese he said Chinese are very
important you know they're very
important for us in the world and we've
got to learn to work with them yes you
know and these are people that kicked
him out of his country they were going
to kill him he had to escape in the
middle of the night he hasn't been able
to go back to Tibet since he was 24 I
think he's 86 now or 85 so you know he I
mean and he's held his people back from
rioting several times to say he
threatened to quit when Tibet in Lhasa
the capital of Tibet started rioting
after right before the Beijing Olympics
in 2012 I believe and so he said I'll
quit if you don't stop this so he is to
me the real deal
and his culture the way they devote
themselves to their practice of reducing
self-importance the the main thing
self-cherishing self-grasping they call
it and reducing chipping away at that
ego with their meditations yeah and
their
and their various religious practices so
yeah okay I don't know how you got on
yeah that's a great as a we we think
that that's some of respecting the
depths of the indigenous cultures around
the world and their wisdoms is is
critical for the new age that we're
heading into um do you think we are in a
simulation oh okay hey what you do right
yeah very nuanced view um you know I'm
sure that's is that very popular in the
high tech community that we are I think
it's more popular with younger people
trying to figure out what's going on
mm-hmm
it's a question for young people's minds
what is this what is this all about is
this some kind of game and do I have
free will or am i destined to pick my
nose right now yeah you know I don't
I don't think it helps the process to
try and figure it out doesn't help my
process so I don't I'm more interested
in practicing kindness and self selfless
acts my wife is a great teacher for me
mm-hmm
she's much more that way than I am and
so and along with the little practice
you just talked about you know the
gratitude practice and that remembering
that we're constantly we are everything
in our daily rituals of breathing and
eating and drinking you know so that's
enough for me to handle and then what do
you think is the most beautiful thing in
the world
oh this is a question you ask everybody
the most beautiful thing in the world
oh boy there's so much beauty in the
world
and the world is beautiful
I don't have a good answer you know I
this you know I the other night I saw
sunset like I've never seen it we are
very fortunate where we live in Seattle
I have a view over this lake and I watch
the Sun go down every night and the lake
turns pure gold and it just did the
other night at that moment that was a
beautiful beautiful thing in there yeah
and I can look at my wife at times and
she's the most beautiful woman in the
world or my son my daughter you know
there's just a lot of things
it's reek of beauty cheesecake yeah
right on yeah yeah yes I've been there
and I fight that I have a real sweet
tooth Wow oh don't y'all like it I feel
so good I feel so good all right ah I
feel thank you so much for coming on the
show yeah thank you and thanks for
giving me a place to sleep tonight
you're super awesome anytime anytime
anytime yeah we I don't know where I am
gonna sleep right now across the street
[Laughter]
supporting the artists the entrepreneurs
the spiritual leaders around the world
so important whether it's a place to
sleep
patreon PayPal cryptocurrency support
them support crazy wise go and watch the
film everyone go and support them also
support us our links are in the bio
below support us help support the people
that you believe in in the world
shout out to Ron Vargas for producing
and directing thank you very much Ronny
and also calling you Ray I'm sorry
no worries Ron it's so good I'll go me
whatever you work out you call you call
me whatever you want
spike
and also have more conversations about
these things with your friends families
co-workers people online on social media
talk more about spirituality talk more
about indigenous wisdom talk more about
these things shared them around the
world everyone get inspired to make
content about it and go and build the
future manifest your dream since the
world thank you very much for tuning in
we will see you soon
[Music]
you